- [Voiceover] Let's get some practice
solving some exponential equations,
and we have one right over here.
We have 26 to the 9x plus five power
equals one.
So, pause the video and
see if you can tell me
what x is going to be.
Well, the key here is to realize that 26
to the zeroth power, to the zeroth power
is equal to one.
Anything to the zeroth power is going
to be equal to one.
Zero to the zeroth power we can discuss
at some other time, but anything other
than zero to the zeroth
power is going to be one.
So, we just have to
say, well, 9x plus five
needs to be equal to zero.
9x plus five
And this is pretty
straightforward to solve.
Subtract five from both sides.
And we get 9x is equal to negative five.
Divide both sides by nine,
and we are left with x is
equal to negative five.
Let's do another one of these,
and let's make it a little bit more,
a little bit more interesting.
Let's say we have the exponential equation
two to the 3x plus five power
is equal to 64
to the x minus seventh power.
Once again, pause the video,
and see if you can tell
me what x is going to be,
or what x needs to be to satisfy
this exponential equation.
All right, so you might, at first, say,
oh, wait a minute,
maybe 3x plus five needs
to be equal to x minus seven,
but that wouldn't work,
because these are two different bases.
You have two to the 3x plus five power,
and then you have 64 to the x minus seven.
So, the key here is to
express both of these
with the same base, and lucky for us,
64 is a power of two, two to the,
let's see, two to the third is eight,
so it's going to be two to the
third times two to the third.
Eight times eight is 64,
so it's two to the sixth is equal to 64,
and you can verify that.
Take six twos and multiply them together,
you're going to get 64.
This was just a little bit easier for me.
Eight times eight, and
this is the same thing
as two to the sixth power, is 64,
and I knew it was two to the sixth power
because I just added the exponents
because I had the same base.
All right, so I can rewrite 64.
Let me rewrite the whole thing.
So, this is two to the 3x plus five power
is equal to, instead of writing 64,
I'm going to write two to the sixth power,
two to the sixth power, and then that
to the x minus seventh power,
x minus seven power.
And to simplify this a little bit,
we just have to remind ourselves
that, if I raise something to one power,
and then I raise that to another power,
this is the same thing as raising my base
to the product of these powers,
a to the bc power.
So, this equation I can rewrite as
two to the 3x plus five is equal to
two to the, and I just multiply six
times x minus 7, so it's going
to be 6x,
6x minus six
times seven is 42.
I'll just write the whole thing in yellow.
So, 6x minus 42, I just multiplied the six
times the entire expression x minus 7.
And so now it's interesting.
I have two to the 3x plus 5 power
has to be equal to two
to the 6x minus 42 power.
So these need to be the same exponent.
So, 3x plus five needs to
be equal to 6x minus 42.
So there we go.
It sets up a nice little
linear equation for us.
3x plus five is equal to 6x minus 42.
Let's see, we could get all of our,
since, I'll put all my Xs
on the right hand side,
since I have more Xs on the right already,
so let me subtract 3x from both sides.
And let me, I want to
get rid of this 42 here,
so let's add 42 to both sides,
and we are going to be left with
five plus 42 is 47,
is equal to, 47 is equal
to 3x.
Now we just divide both sides by three,
and we are left with x is
equal to 47 over three.
X is equal to 47 over three.
And we are done.